I think in 2022 if you're complaining
about the pay Gap as a woman you're
probably just lazy um I have never had a
problem getting the same pay as a guy
one issue is that women don't ask for
raises so 60 of women have never asked
for a raise and they quit before they
ask for a raise so how can we be afraid
or how can we be mad that we don't get
paid as much if we don't ask for more
for more money
um second thing I would say is that you
know we work less hours so they do
studies where they see how many hours a
girl works and we actually get paid more
when you account for hours work and the
industries we choose we'll talk about
equal pay when it comes or equal you
know they want us to be in like the one
percent and all that stuff but they
never talk about the positions like
plumbers prickling any of the hard jobs
women don't want to do so we get paid
less because we don't like to do hard
jobs or ask for raises